this game literally just came out it
seems wonderful just look at that aren't
you just happy we play a lot of goofy
games we play a lot of horror games I
play a lot of shitty games but this game
just looks really nice and it's good to
play a nice game for a change you know
and here we are
oh my god this is amazing
walking to Pillar why not best game ever
you're Betty go away stupid Betty's by
the power of kawaii I Strigoi you to
cease to exist so happy happy Oh
oh no I can't kill you why don't I kill
them I don't know why these are two pair
of breasteses wonderful so now app what
360 noscope oh yeah love this game this
game is amaze
jump into the pillar because that's life
oh no what did i do that's right
[Music]
whoa face clamp or dispatch what is that
whoa did you see that unrealistic [ __ ] I
can't stand on the boob pillars for too
long apparently oh yeah this give us
harder than I thought
jump into the pillar answer
[Music]
[ __ ] emoji why can't you all just see
you I'm so [ __ ] can't but he
why can't you see a [ __ ] cat
but it I am I'm but the [ __ ] cat just
look at my butt
look how it flows in the way and what am
I going I know nobody no one and no one
about if no one maybe down here
that was not day by day and say why did
you tell me Timmy strippers boobs get
out of the way sad I never say that I
feel like the blasphemy or some [ __ ] try
going oh my god the pillar is right
there I don't fit I'm so sick you think
you're fab well have you seen my nips
have you seen field trips calm now well
then don't talk to me all right look at
this look at this so many 360s I didn't
even count them there might have been
one but what are you in a bad light it's
not a sausage rocket oh my god with
extra mustard I almost got it lonely
that's amazing
this game should be the new college cuz
holy [ __ ] it's beats them all whoever
made this game please contact Treyarch
and just tell them what to do there we
go this is how it's done risen I tried
fish I said that right my god the power
of Chi way man if everyone displayed
this game there will be no war there
would only be a lot about sex I mean lot
of love what will state but it's it's
hard man it's hard but in a good way
like a penis I said I went there so I
went there sometimes I go there that's
all the best been suffering man Timmy do
you have to stand so [ __ ] close to
him God God Jimmy fishy what do you base
your not an order to man god damn it I
don't understand the boobs there we go
girl
amazing okay bad start a nipple whoa
bouncing EPS Oh
denied ow maybe not now jump and at em
multi shot and an ample DS shining and
the name the tee shots huh and be shot
everybody shot everybody
don't just can't you see cuz I'm a
[ __ ] emojis son huh why can't
you just see I'm up the [ __ ] good Nick
oh oh oh this gave me the pure joy to
play love it love it
this makes up for all the shitty games I
played today cuz holy [ __ ] what's there
a lot of shitty games Timmy Timmy get
your [ __ ] together man there we go fine
finally she got a restraining face man
god damn that's face daddy's face main
battery if you don't know [ __ ] yeah shut
up on top like that boom you gotta be so
fast
Jesus Christ this is a challenge I tell
her a true challenge get all that side
give me all this yeah what's up Oh son
Oh Timmy did you see that
let me burn a buncha Timmy boom oh man
that's a good one Timmy got a love
motorboating Timmy 360 no-scope - OH
[ __ ] emoji pump can't you see
and Maddie came to see it Oh Kate you
see aunt birdee
can't you see tape me what're you doin
girl oh did you guys see that fanger
let's go while fangirls go hon oh my god
slap my ass slap it slap it slap it slap
it slap it up you slapped you hard
Oh what you gonna do about my shampoo
huh you watch you gonna [ __ ] what's up
with that one in the face holy [ __ ] I'm
starting my new Falcon lover sighing man
cuz holy [ __ ] I'm good so what do we do
after this [ __ ] like where do I go
there's a nip here oh my god nip to
space Nick to space oh my god what how
am I sick come on all right here we go
nips to space where do I go oh there
this that is a can't reach it
[ __ ] say my water ballon I'm water below
oh so good this gave the Majin so the
capital Zed [ __ ] me she's really got the
the district oldest steps up in the butt
man and I like it that's a good step up
in the bite if you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] to you not today Timmy Kim isn't it
man
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Ted's man alright watch
me get this with hundred percent
accuracy watch oh it's so far not so
[ __ ] bad huh Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya Ya
oh that goes go crazy
let show me their tits yeah
[Music]
what's up oh what's up fangirls Timmy's
fight almost Ryan girls name is Timmy
everyone elseís it's common fact I have
it in analytics on YouTube don't even
worry about it
where do I go nipple when in doubt
nipple that's what I always said my mom
always said that at least actually
that's really weird
take that back edit that out Fitz this
is too weird
oh what's up ain't my butt what's up
and my butt what's up it my butt what's
up a shopping bag I'm not shopping all
right fresh that's a great game hope you
enjoyed watching this video I have a lot
of fun playing it's nice to change it up
a little bit it wasn't a while play
actual fun game there you go you got
your horror portion thank you for
hanging out with me today bros it's been
awesome thank you for leaving like and
I'll see you tomorrow
stay awesome